vous voyez ce gros heavy metal que les
parents déteste qu'on écoute cause et
toutes ses chansons sur l'enfer et le
jugement dernier
si je vous disais que tout ça c'est vrai
je vous jure
j'aidais
[ __ ] laudebat c'est de la pisse
voilà c'est moi brody mes potes sont des
losers on a décidé de monter un groupe
c'est débile mats et qui d'ailleurs
et non
pas carrément dingue si la musique avait
quelque chose à voir avec les des nains
les démons on va tous crever ok j'ai
traduit la partition et maintenant tout
le monde devient dingue genre posséder
9 c'était plutôt cool ou avec l'âge
c'est quoi je me demande si elle est
bien accorder frère de métal